hey guys how's it going today we are
bringing you a very fun festive holiday
video and we're going to show you how to
wrap presents this is my challenge that
I've never wrapped before me either at
all no so we partnered with Walmart
because you basically can get absolutely
anything there from socks to tech to
everything in between like name
something in between up next last time
we went we got those little snacks on
the thing we did and you bought
flip-flops thank you I wear those all
the time now and while we were catching
pokémon in the place before my weight
anyway this year we're ready for the
holidays and getting ready early we have
gifts for everyone
first up present for mom and dad should
we bring it over yes I'm gonna zoom out
so would only pay zoom out zoom out your
carpet so I'm pretty excited so this is
the 5000 65-inch 4k ultra HDTV so my dad
has an older TV and every time we go
home I you know selfishly like when I
play call of duty and video games on it
I'm like dad can we get a bigger TV so
and I'm always like dad how am I
supposed to watch Netflix know how the
heck are we going dress well I like
these legs I do too real sleek real
sleek look okay like though what's that
sir but this will be the emergency one
bo what you got up there this is the
Vizio D series Smart TV features full
array LED backlighting and 16 active led
zones I hope you like gonna wrap this
around
one of the things it was most important
for my parents I wanted to give them a
4k TV but I also wanted to get them a
smart TV so they be able to pretty much
watch anything now today it's a smart
furious Netflix not enough for netflix
and chill' when you go home sit good
well the stripe theme is not exactly
know speaking in the present there's not
gonna need the people to see it is
working nicely yep I don't think you're
ready for this looks good and we've got
our next gift this is the Roku a 55 inch
ultra high-definition TV let's worry
about this is the ease of use of Roku
streaming now my sister she's I wouldn't
say she's a most tech-savvy person in
the world she doesn't watch a lot of TV
watches a lot of youtube watches a ton
of Netflix so for her this is gonna be
absolutely perfect and her husband also
is a huge gamer so I think that he is
going to really love this one
the banks was gonna be into this I'm
freezing like this could be she's always
on her phone so instead of using the
remote she can also use the Roku
streaming app mm streaming channel
really yes whoa great for mobile premium
that you quality Hey look what we can do
what this is genius
got it
look looks dry it looks bad another one
this is actually a present that Jenna
got me this is a hatch Amol okay let's
wrap it present he's always talking
about how he wants to make his chili
it's a Wi-Fi enabled slow cooker mostly
short end he wants everything to be
connected to his phone his lights
everything so he likes cooking so we saw
this over like ed and also doesn't like
to waste time so we're not even gonna
wrap it and here's your present Jenna do
you want your present did you give me a
present I did yeah this is a very good
friend so this is basically a
housewarming gift so happy merry happy
holiday thank you I actually need this I
have one pant in my apartment
that I use for like everything I can
make our risotto and this time for
mistletoe and we won last gift to floor
my friend Desiree hopefully she doesn't
watch this video either cuz this is
definitely a surprise so she had a son
and he is obsessed with like drawing and
playing with tablets he's only two but I
was watching him and like play on her
phone and stuff and I was like all right
I've got something for you so I saw one
of these and it's super small this is a
little nova yoga book I had one of the
Lenovo yoga book pros and it was really
really big and had like this projector
in it I think was pretty much nothing
yeah it was super cool so this is
awesome because it's definitely super
small and it also looks really durable
which is gonna be great for children
great for children baby's first okay
thank you so much for watching I will
see you guys in the next video let me
know in the comments below what your
most favorite gifts that you've ever
received or your favorite gift that
you've ever given I think so far general
it's pretty cool I'm looking forward to
seeing well it's of watching it hatch a
huge thank you to all my for partnering
with us on this video and so you guys
like but a little look at it
you can look from afar okay obody are
you excited
with a bigger feel like it takes away
from the experience
yeah